عملت مراسلا واعرف معنى الشقاء في هذه
المهنه انا الان اتمشى في استوديو نظيف
اقرا من الاوتوكيو زميلي يسعفني بالماء
اذا ما زعلت لكن المراسل الميداني يمضي
معظم نهاره في الحرف البرد في الطين في
الجوع والعطش في العرق والدبق والخطر
احيانا ليطلعك على اخر الاحداث وقت حدوثها
احد مراسلي قناه الاخباريه السعوديه اسمه
محمد الشيخ كان ضمن طاقمي القناه في تغطيه
عمليه اجراء رعايه المملكه ودول الصديقه
من السودان الى ميناء جده محمد طبعا يظهر
على راس الساعه لتحديث الاخبار حول هذا
الموضوع ظل على هذا الحال لمده شهر تقريبا
في ذلك الميناء في السودان يبدو ان
الارهاق تمكن منه واغني عليه عندما كان
على الهواء مباشره شاهد
مصورنا محمد الغامدي امام امامنا هنا في
عدسه الاخباريه لربما من على مسافه ليست
ببعيده قد تصل سفينه جلاله الملكه الرياض
في غضون
عشر الى خمسه عشر دقيقه شكرا لك محمد شيخ
مراسل الاخباريه من جده
لاحظتم كيف سقط لكن هناك شخص حاول الامساك
به رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي تعاطفوا
مع
اصحاب هذه المهنه الشاقه الذين يعني يؤدون
عملهم
بتعب جديد نايف الاحمدي يقول لك بعض
المراسلين يتعب حتى ينقل لك صوره من الحدث
اغماء الصديق المجتهد محمد الشيخ مراسل
قناه الاخباريه الف سلامه عليك يا صديقي
عبد الحكيم قال لك الصوره التي تراها تنقل
لك في ثواني خلفها ابطال ظلوا يتعبون
بساعات حتى تنقل لك الحدث في جوده عاليه
ابو عبد الله ابو عبد الله قال في التغريد
المراسلون حسب عملهم المرهق بعض الاحيان
ما ينامون اكثر من يوم الله يساعدهم يونس
قال جميل يقول بعض المراسلين يتعب حتى
ينقل لك الصوره ويكون عينك في مواقع
الاحداث الف لا باس
يتحدث الى محمد اما محمد فقال انا بخير
الحمد لله شكرا الرائده البحري الذي ظهر
في الفيديو وهو يسرع نحو بدر بن ابراهيم
خلف الوقت داني انقذ راسي من الارتطام
اعلنت الخارجيه السعوديه على انتهاء كامله
عمليات الاجلاء لمواطنيها ورعايا الدول
الشقيقه والصديقه من السودان وقالت عمليات
الاجلاء شملت 800 او ثمانيه
الافادهم بواسطه سفن وطائرات القوات
الملكيه السعوديه وساعدت دولا ايضا باجلاء
احد عشر الفا و184 شخصا من المملكه الى
المملكه ثم الى اوطانهم